a bold new plan from president biden to
beat the pandemic
he says the government will soon buy
another 200 million vaccine doses
and the goal is to get 300 million
americans vaccinated by the fall that
would be the bulk of this country's
population
ed o'keefe is at the white house for us
ed good morning to you
i'm hearing a lot of optimism coming
from the president considering how bad
things are but it's only a plan right
now those vaccines are not in hand
what else is in the plan yeah good
morning tony look if you're somebody
sitting at home who's been trying to get
the vaccine and you've been told by
local officials that supply is low
just know that you're not alone that's
because governors have been telling the
new biden administration in recent days
that they're having vaccines supply
issues so part of this new plan is to
try to boost vaccine supply
by about 10 million doses for at least
the next three weeks it's also been hard
to plan ahead at the state level
so the president says that communication
is a big part
of his new plan we're going to get this
done
president biden vowing certainty and
consistency as part of his new plan to
fight coronavirus
and promising that states will get more
of a heads up on how many shots to
expect
we've had to guess how much vaccine to
expect
for the next week this is unacceptable
the
you know the lives are at stake here for
weeks governors have complained they
can't make better vaccine distribution
plans because the federal government is
giving them little warning of how many
shots to expect
the past federal they made
so many people eligible but there was so
little supply
that disconnect is creating this public
confusion and anxiety new york governor
andrew cuomo was on a call tuesday with
officials
leading the federal response the federal
administration will now
tell the states how much they're getting
for the next three weeks and they're
increasing the allocation
that's a big deal for a state like new
york as he announced the 200 million
more vaccine doses will be delivered by
the end of the summer
the president set a big new goal it'll
be enough to fully vaccinate
300 americans to beat this pandemic 300
million americans
among those getting the vaccine vice
president harris who got her second
shot on tuesday take the vaccine when it
is your turn
it will save your life and hundreds of
white house staffers are being
vaccinated with plans to give shots to
everyone working at 1600 pennsylvania
avenue
in the coming weeks as we hit the one
week mark of the biden presidency
today's theme here is fighting climate
change the president will sign
several executive orders designed to do
that including a new ban on offshore oil
drilling
that the oil industry already says they
don't like but also happening today dr
anthony fauci and other top medical and
science officials will hold their first
briefing with reporters
the white house says that team will be
holding them at least three times a week
in order to keep the public updated
on the pandemic response michelle
staying busy ed
thank you